PER SESSION HONORING HIS SECOND
INAUGURATION.
SO MUCH FOR HISTORY.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE ON
TOMORROW'S EVENT IS WHITE HOUSE
PRINCIPAL DEPUTY PRESS SECRETARY
HOGAN GIVE DEAN DENNY.
GOOD TO TALK TO YOU, ONE IS
TEMPTED TO CONCLUDE THAT TO THE
LEFT AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
WHICH IS REDUNDANT I REALIZE
HAVE NO CLUE ABOUT AMERICAN
HISTORY AND TRADITION.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE FORGOTTEN THAT
WE SECURED OUR INDEPENDENCE THAT
WE CELEBRATE TOMORROW THROUGH
MILITARY FORCE.
YOU KNOW, GENERAL WASHINGTON IN
THE CONTINENTAL CONGRESS, THAT
LITTLE THING CALLED THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR, WHAT IS YOUR
TAKE?
>> IT IS PRETTY CLEAR AT THIS
POINT TO THAT THE DEMOCRATS IN
THIS COUNTRY HATE THIS PRESIDENT
MORE THAN THEY LOVE AMERICA.
AND THAT HATRED HAS TAKEN MANY
FORMS IN THE SHORT PERIOD THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
FIRST THE DEMOCRATS LIED ABOUT
COLLUSION, THEN THEY LIED ABOUT
THE CORRUPTION.
THEN THEY LIED ABOUT THE CRISIS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
AND NOW THEY ARE LYING ABOUT THE
MOTIVES OF DONALD TRUMP.
WHO SIMPLY WANTS TO CELEBRATE TO
THE GREATEST IDEA EVER REALIZED
IN THE HISTORY OF HUMANKIND.
AND THAT IS AMERICA.
MOST COUNTRIES WHO HAVE A
CONSTITUTION, THOSE
CONSTITUTIONS LAST AN AVERAGE OF
ABOUT 17 YEARS.
OURS HAS BEEN AROUND FOR MORE
THAN 230.
THIS IS NO DOUBT THE MOST
AMAZING PLACE IN HISTORY.
AND DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO
CELEBRATE THAT GREATNESS, REFUSE
TO EVEN CELEBRATE OUR NATION'S
INDEPENDENCE OR THE
FOURTH OF JULY SIMPLY BECAUSE IT
IS DONALD TRUMP WHO IS DOING THE
CELEBRATING.
>> Gregg: I SAID MY FAVORITE
WAS THE COMMENTATOR WHO SAID OH,
THINGS FLYING OVERHEAD.
REALLY THE FAVORITE WAS THE CLIP
THAT WE PLAYED OF THE EVER
OBTUSE JOY REID ON MSNBC WHO
SAID, YOU KNOW, THE TANKS ARE A
THREAT.
AS IF THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
DIRECT THE MILITARY TO TURN THE
TANKS ON THE PEOPLE AND FIRE
AWAY.
HAS THE ANTIPATHY TOWARDS TRUMP
BECOME SO EXTREME NOW THAT THESE
PEOPLE HAVE LOST ALL SENSE?
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT, LISTEN, I
WAS WITH THE PRESIDENT FOR QUITE
SOME TIME THIS AFTERNOON TALKING
ABOUT THE SPEECH AND LISTENING
TO HIM TALK ABOUT THE THEMES
THAT HE WANTS TO ADDRESS.
AND THERE IS NOT A POLITICAL
BONE IN THE ENTIRE SPEECH.
I MEAN, THE WHOLE THING IS ABOUT
THE GREATNESS OF AMERICA.
HOW FAR WE HAVE COME.
AND YES, WE HAVE HAD DARK DAYS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO MANY OTHER NATIONS HAVE HAD
DARK DAYS.
THE DARKNESS IS NOT UNIQUE.
WHAT IS UNIQUE TO AMERICA IS
THAT WE CAME OUT OF THOSE DARK
DAYS BETTER AND MORE UNITED.
IN AMAZING PEOPLE.
UNITED BEHIND THE IDEAL THAT IS
AMERICA.
THAT'S WHAT THE SPEECH IS ABOUT
AND WHAT DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO
CAN BE.
HE WANTS TO CELEBRATE THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE BRAVE AND PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND ALLOW THE
FREEDOMS OF THOSE JOURNALIST TO
MAKE THOSE CLAIMS ALBEIT
COMPLETELY FALSE.
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
FOR ALL AMERICANS.
IT IS NOT POLITICAL OR ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS ABOUT EACH OF US.
THAT'S WHAT HE WANTS TO CONVEY.